R
BEING ON THE PROGRAM.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Lawrence: NOW TURNING TO
BOMBSHELL REVELATION DONALD
TRUMP INSISTED PEOPLE INSIDE HIS
ADMINISTRATION WERE WORKING TO
UNDERMINE HIS PRESIDENCY AND IT
TURNS OUT HE WAS RIGHT.
AS A NEW BOOK FROM BOB WOODWARD
AND ROBERT O. KOSTA REVEALS
CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MILLEY FOUGHT TO
UNDERMINE TRUMP WHILE HE SERVED
AS COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
MILLIE HAD AT LEAST TWO PHONE
CALLS WITH HIS COUNTERPART IN
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT WHERE HE
LOOKED TO REASSURE THE COMMUNIST
NATION THAT THE U.S. WOULDN'T BE
LAUNCHING AN ATTACK.
CALLS ARE ALREADY GROWING FOR
MILLIE TO BE FIRED OVER THESE
OFFENSES AND IF TRUE, HE HAS A
LOT TO ANSWER FOR IN TWO WEEKS
WHEN HE TESTIFIES BEFORE
CONGRESS, LET'S BRING IN FORMER
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY AND
CO-HOST OF OUTNUMBERED KAYLEIGH
McENANY.
KAYLEIGH, I DEFINITELY WANTED
YOU TO BE ON THE PROGRAM TO
ANSWER TO THIS BECAUSE YOU WERE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION.
DID YOU ALL SUSPECT THIS WAS
GOING ON?
>> NO.
I MEAN, LOOK, IT WAS EYE OPENING
WHEN WE WALKED TO THE CHURCH.
I WAS WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
ST. JOHN'S CHURCH WE ALL
REMEMBER WHEN IT BURNED IN THAT
RIOT.
I WALKED WITH GENERAL MILLEY.
I WALKED WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
THAT CHURCH.
GENERAL MILLEY WAS THERE.
HE HAPPILY OBLIGED IN THAT
MOVEMENT.
AND THEN THE DAY AFTER
APOLOGIZED AND SAID THAT HE
SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE IT.
SO, CERTAINLY THAT WAS
EYE-OPENING.
BUT, LAWRENCE, YOU KNOW, I HAVE
GOT TO SAY THIS.
MY JAW DROPPED OPEN TODAY WHEN I
SAW THIS REPORTING.
I HOPE IT'S NOT TRUE AND I SAY I
HOPE IT'S NOT TRUE BECAUSE I
DON'T TRUST THE REPORTING OF BOB
WOODWARD, UNLIKE MOST
JOURNALISTS, LIBERAL JOURNALISTS
WHO JUST BUY IT HOOK, LINE AND
SINKER, I DON'T.
I QUESTION IT.
BUT, IF THIS IS TRUE, LAWRENCE,
IF THIS IS TRUE, THAT IN THE
VERY OVAL OFFICE I WAS SITTING
IN THAT GENERAL MILLEY WAS
TALKING TO THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND OUTSIDE OF THOSE
MEETINGS WAS BACK CHANNELING TO
CHINA SAYING I WILL LET YOU KNOW
IF THERE IS EVER AN ATTACK ON
YOU?
I'M PARAPHRASING THERE?
IF THAT WAS HAPPENING, THAT IS
AIDING AND ABETTING THE ENEMY.
THERE IS A WORD WE HAVE FOR THAT
I WON'T SAY IT BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT TO GET THERE YET BECAUSE I
DON'T TRUST THE REPORTING OF BOB
WOODWARD BUT THAT IS SIMPLY
STUNNING IN EVERY SENSE OF THE
WORD.
>> Lawrence: KAYLEIGH WE KNOW
LEAKS WERE HAPPENING OBAMA WHEN
HE HAD LEAKS HE WENT AFTER HIS
LEAKERS, WE STILL DON'T KNOW WHO
THE LEAKERS WERE.
ACTUALLY WE KNOW ONE OF THEM
VINDMAN WHO HAS ALREADY SAID AND
WE GOT A TWEET FROM HIM.
THAT MILLIE NEEDS TO RESIGN.
>> YEAH.
EXACTLY.
BECAUSE CIVILIANS CONTROL THE
MILITARY.
THE CIVILIAN COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF
NOT THE MILITARY GENERAL WHO IS
NOT ONLY BACK CHANNELING TO
CHINA BUT ALSO SAYING, YOU KNOW,
BUCK THE ORDERS IF THERE WAS
EVER AN ORDER ON THE NUCLEAR
FRONT.
YOU KNOW, BUCK THOSE ORDERS IS
ESSENTIALLY IS WHAT HE WAS
SAYING.
LAWRENCE, I HAVE TO ASK, THE GUY
WHO SAYS THAT HE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN LEADING THE WAY, HE IS THE
RIGHT ONE ON FOREIGN POLICY ON
NATIONAL SECURITY.
WHILE I DO HAVE THIS REPORTING
THAT I TALKED TO A VERY HIGH
LEVEL INTELLIGENCE OFFICIAL, WHO
TOLD ME THIS, HE SAID HE SAT IN
THE OVAL.
I WAS NOT IN THIS MEETING.
BUT HE WAS ASKED BY PRESIDENT
TRUMP HOW LONG WOULD IT TAKE FOR
AFGHANISTAN TO FALL IF THERE WAS
NOT AN INTERIM GOVERNMENT IN
PLACE, A COALITION GOVERNMENT?
THAT HIGH LEVEL INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIAL SAID VERY QUICKLY,
MR. PRESIDENT.
TO RESPONDED IT WOULD FALL IN
TWO DAYS.
HE SAID THIS IN FRONT OF GENERAL
MILLEY WHO THEN WENT ONTO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO
ORCHESTRATING THE DEVASTATING
FALL OF AFGHANISTAN WHERE 13
SERVICE MEMBERS DIED.
I TRUST THE GUY WHO SAID
AFGHANISTAN IS GOING TO FALL IN
TWO DAYS NOT THE GUY WHO SAT IN
THE MEETING AND FAILED TO
COMMUNICATE THAT INFORMATION TO
THE NEXT COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF WHO
THEN OVERSAW THE FALL OF
AFGHANISTAN AND THE DEVASTATING
IMAGES WE ALL SAW.
>> Lawrence: NOT JUST THAT
KAYLEIGH, AS YOU HAVE NOTED
BEFORE, THIS IS THE GUY THAT
MADE THE CALL JUST THE OTHER DAY
WHERE THEY NOW GOT THE WRONG GUY
AND THEY TARGETINGED CIVILIAN.
>> ALL KNOWING.
>> YES.
IT'S THE GUY WHO CALLED IT A
RIGHTEOUS STRIKE, A RIGHTEOUS
STRIKE WHICH KEEP IN MIND
PRESIDENT BIDEN, THIS IS HIS
ADMINISTRATION, THE RIGHTEOUS
STRIKE THAT KILLED A
HUMANITARIAN AIDE WORKER THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTING AND
SEVEN CHILDREN AND THE GUY WAS
CARRYING WATER BOTTLES BUT, YET,
THEY TARGET HIM AS IF HE IS AN
ISIS-K MEMBER.
WE HAVE MORE TO THE STORY TO
COME OUT.
WE HAVE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORT
SOMETHING TRUE.
BUT YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
HE IS GREEN LIGHTED THE RIGHT TO
STRIKE THAT ENDED IN THE DEATH
OF SEVEN CHILDREN.
>> Lawrence: YOU KNOW, KAYLEIGH,
I KNOW SCIENTISTS BUT I BELIEVE
MY EYES, ALL I CAN SAY IS I KNOW
A DIFFERENCE FROM THE MILLIE IN
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
THEN WHEN THEY WALKED OVER TO
THE CHURCH TO NOW.
IT SEEMS LIKE THERE HAS BEEN A
LITTLE FLIP-FLOPPING GOING ON
MILLIE.
AM I MISSING SOMETHING?
>> NO.
IT CERTAINLY DOES.
AND, LAWRENCE, I LEARNED THIS
THE HARD WAY.
YOU KNOW, WE HEAR ABOUT THE DEEP
STATE AND, YOU KNOW, THE FOLKS
OVER AT LIBERAL NEWS NETWORKS
SAY IT DOESN'T EXIST IT DOES
EXIST, LAWRENCE.
I COMMUNICATED WITH THE DEEP
STATE IN THE HALLWAYS.
I CAN TELL YOU THE PEOPLE VERY
NICE TO YOUR FACE AFTERMATH THAT
THEY DR. FAUCI FOR DECADES
MAKING WRONG DECISIONS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, ON
FAUCI'S PART SAYING MASKS WORK.
THEY DON'T WORK, YOU KNOW,
TRYING TO SAVE MASKS FOR OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKERS BUT LYING TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THEY ARE
NICE TO YOUR FACE.
THEY ARE PART OF THE DEEP STATE.
BUT THEY ARE UNDERMINING THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF ALONG THE WAY
REPUBLICAN COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF AS
THEY DID TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Lawrence: UNDERMINING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO GET THE ADULTS BACK IN THE
ROOM, COMPLETELY MESSED THIS
ENTIRE SITUATION UP.
I GUESS ELECTIONS DO HAV